[Music]
five that is correct but my
understanding is um and i just want to
make sure this is correct number five is
going to be played
that's okay i'm sorry number five
played in the courtroom
but all five events in terms of the
admissibility of them you have
stipulated to the admission of
alzheimer's
um
the issue that you want to address with
the court before we start do you have
twisted up at the bench no
um when my client is seated and writing
down on her lap the camera can focus in
on her papers and
it has
um i would ask that the cameras not be
allowed to focus on papers and the media
explicitly be told that cannot happen
um
thank you
okay we are back on the record on people
versus jennifer chromeblade and people
versus james crumbly um the defense
council has brought up an issue relative
to
any filming and or photographing of
notes taken by the by the attorneys and
or the defendants
i am going to direct the media do not
zero in or take any photographs of their
notes to each other that is prohibited
strictly prohibited and that is
attorney-client communication
and it is not to be divulged in any way
shape or form
okay
okay you're ready to call your next
witness
prosecution called capital
yes
you may have to keep your voice up for
me
you can have a seat twist
if you could scoot as close as you can
to those microphones i'd appreciate it
um i am going to ask you to please keep
your voice up when testifying so that
everybody can hear you and he can record
you additionally it is um it's very
important for you to verbalize all
responses okay if you shake your head or
say uh-huh or on my court reporter
cannot record that okay yes
again i'm gonna ask you to keep your
voice up yes all right all right um
first i'd like you to state and spell
your first and last name for me
kathy polyquin k-a-t-h-y
p-o-l-i-q-u-i-n thank you
the groundwork here you work for a
real estate management company correct
okay what's your title there director of
human resources okay and again
remembering to try to match the volume
of my voice um what are your what do you
oversee what are your tools
i oversee all human resource functions
all the employees in all of our
locations including our corporate office
anything dealing with payroll benefits
um
disciplinary hiring firing anything
human resource related and how long have
you done that jack 16 years okay do you
know jennifer
yes do you know james
no do you see jennifer here in courtroom
yes can you describe something she's
wearing her
what she's wearing a black and white
jumpsuit nathan my room that she's
properly
when did you first meet jennifer crumbly
almost five years ago
is that when she began working there yes
all right and when she was hired what
was her position
a marketing assistant
what was her position at the time she
left she was terminated
and what was your
interaction with
jennifer how frequent was your
interactions
did you ever uh socialize or see her
outside
in what capacity
just a few facebook
texts
um
casual okay were you friends
friendly friends
and did she ever share anything personal
with you
very minimal
did you what did you know about her
based on what she told you
yeah uh i know she loves horses
i know that she worked at the
ski patrol
i said what
and just minimally giving me some
information when her husband had lost a
job
and took a job with four dash
and when did she tell you he took the
job george
two months ago
did you know she had a son yes
did she talk about him much
no
did you um would you describe your
workplace family friendly yes what
our core values is family first
so what exactly is that
well
if anybody needed to
attend to a family issue they had to
leave for an emergency
it was never said no you know go attend
to your your
concerns or your problems
and
and that's it we never you know held
anyone back and did you um did jennifer
directly report to you no so when did
you interact with her with regard is it
hey hours
sometimes usually she would help me with
employment and postings on social media
okay
and
when employees need to take time off
what's the procedure
procedure they are to ask permission
from their immediate supervisor first
and then they enter their time into the
payroll system for pto patient law and
has eto accumulated
it is upon higher they would have earned
40 out 48 hours at 90 days
and then at one year of employment they
would earn 88 hours of pto
two years they would earn 120 hours of
pto in five years and beyond it would be
160
and as part of your job do you keep
trying with that yeah i do through our
payroll system do you manage um the
uh documents and records related to
benefits and
time off and employment yes okay do you
do you know
if jennifer had any pto time on november
30th meaning if she had to take time off
what was that available to her yes i
believe she had 12 hours of pto
remaining at that time
do you follow jennifer on social media
i am facebook friends i don't
really follow
does the company offer health insurance
yes does it offer health insurance for a
single person and a family yes
was jennifer's son covered under health
insurance no
was jennifer covered under college yes
was james no
does your
policy provide any assistance or
insurance for mental health treatment
yes
you said you uh are associated with
jennifer on social media did you ever
see a post about a gun
yes do you remember when you
what was your reaction
to the post about the gun and her son
i was kind of like
okay i wouldn't have done that but kind
of moved along
okay and what why were you i'm not sure
how to characterize the um
but would you say
you thought it was odd or different or
it's not something you would do
words in your mouth not really
appropriate but why
um something i would not have done very
much
did jennifer ever talk to you about guns
no did she ever talk to you about her
son
no
do you know jennifer was at work on
november 29th
yes
you know that summer or
it was reported that she was at work it
was recorded on her time
okay did you see jennifer on november
30th
no did you talk to her yes
and
do you know she came into work that day
no
you don't know or she didn't no i don't
know okay i didn't understand okay so
but at some point you talked where one
how did that come about i only
talked to her when andy smith came into
my office
and got
done on his cell phone
and what was jen do you remember about
what time that was
had the news of the oxford school
shooting and made public at that point
i don't know do you know if you knew
anything about it before he came into
your office
okay
what what was jennifer saying on the
she's very hysterical i don't recall
verbatim
very hysterical she was trying to get to
the school
um
i believe she was talking about you know
the gun is missing
when she said the gun did you know what
gun she was talking about i was assuming
it was her hand
and
did you ever see
the um the the exhibit that's up um on
the screen in the math worksheet
yes when did you see it
i saw it at the same time andy smith
came into my office put it down on the
phone
he put his cell phone down and pulled up
a picture of that on his phone
and did you take a good look at it
what was your thought
my first thought was this morning's
means
did you say anything about it no
you were just listening
and at some point
did you talk to jennifer again that day
yes how many times
maybe
one or two i don't recall how many
and what was the purpose of the did she
call you or did you mother
called me i did not call her okay and
will you ever adopt any calls that she
and andy had to do
okay what was the purpose of the cause
from jennifer i recall one conversation
she was afraid to lose her job do you
remember what time that was i don't
recall the exact time
was it during the work hours it was
during workout okay
and what was your response
our response was to
tend to your family and
don't worry about work
just tend to your family let's talk
about it next week
did you get another request to come to
about work yes and what was it
it was uh same request that she didn't
want to lose her job she was afraid to
lose her job
and um
another senior leadership nancy lutfey
was with us on the phone has been stated
that she was going to be on
administrative leave
for the next couple of weeks
and just to not worry
about about
what did you say
thank you
she said to tell our
senior leadership thank you
she thought she could possibly come in a
few days later maybe for a half a day to
get her mind off things later that week
the day
on an administrative need
don't don't worry about coming into work
we'll talk please
and did you ever hear jennifer asked to
leave work to take ethan to
the doctor
no do you know
did she ever talk about him getting any
kind of metaphor
no all right did she ever talk about her
horses getting medical attention
uh
i think a few times she had mentioned
that
the horse was sick okay
oh yes your honor
um
i want to go through the um
november 30th date with you
um
when you were with it sounds like andy
smith um
and he came into your office with
jennifer on the phone do you recall that
yes
and you testified that she was
hysterical did i get that right
can you describe what it means when you
can you describe what you mean by that
i don't recall exactly what she was
saying i know she was just very upset
she was trying to get to the school
uh i believe she said the roads were
closed off she was having a difficult
time
getting there
we had
said to her call the police she said
james already did
the gun was missing
but she was
she was just
um
i i can't put i i don't recall exactly
what she said that she was just
really um upset and hysterical did she
sound panicked panic yeah yes was she
talking fast
yes
um
you you and andy were trying to just get
her to at least stay calm is that
correct yes
was it it was a separate phone call um
when judd was asking if she still had
her job is that correct yes and she told
you part of the reason she didn't want
to she she told me she didn't know how
to handle this correct
yes and
she doesn't know she told you
um she needed information from you so
that she could get money to pay for a
lawyer is that correct
yes i think she wanted check stones you
would be the person to contact for check
stubs or verification of employment
correct yes
and jennifer explicitly said she needs
to get a loan to pay to pay to have a
lawyer correct yes so any kind of check
stubs or
uh documents you needed to prepare
she would have asked you for those
materials correct
as an active employee she still had
access to her checkstones
she just had to log into the payroll
system
okay but if like for example and
a loan officer needed documentation or
something as the hr person you you can
send those materials along correct yes
um
you
now as you were talking to
uh mr crumbly she also
sent you a different email address
um to send
uh any materials to from her pay stubs
and things like that correct yes she
indicated you her outlook isn't working
um and she needed you to use this other
address yes
so the bulk of your conversation is
really about these logistics about
pay stubs this is happening and in the
background you know she's driving to the
school she's frantic
trying to get there correct
she wasn't driving to the school about
the conversation with checks dogs i'm
sorry so the check subs conversation was
after she had already been at the school
yes it's fair to say during that
conversation she still sounded upset and
not like her normal self she was upset
not as
hysterical as she was
um when you spoke with police you told
them how um jennifer had offered to come
back to work do you recall that
yes and specifically you said that
jennifer said she wanted to come back to
work maybe half days the following week
do you recall telling law enforcement
that
i don't recall but
i may have does that sound accurate it
sounds it
um
if anything you and anyone else from the
company um that you were with that day
was supportive to jennifer crumbly
correct yes um everyone at your office
that you were around that day was
surprised by what was taking place at
oxford school
high school
miss crumbly was also asking you
questions about how much is in her 401k
things along those lines correct yes
and she's trying to get the company id
for sites like paylocity is that a
a
payroll company you use yes
um
you were trying to help her with that
because even that site was having issues
that day is that correct yes
so a lot of your conversations with jen
regarding her employment
um
hr issues
those are not topics that would surprise
you that jennifer would call you about
correct
if jennifer
in the past was having an argument with
ethan or something along those lines
that's not something jennifer would have
come and talked to you about correct
that's right if she had done that that
would be
unusual
yes we didn't have that kind of
relationship
so you had um certainly a professional
relationship
yes where the questions about her job
payroll pay stubs proof of employment
were relevant to what you do for the
company
yes
um your office is not far from
jennifer's where jennifer sits is that
correct
it is uh a good distance away
you've been down by her desk
and you've seen that she has family
photographs and things like that yes
on her facebook uh feed you saw the
photograph um of the gun
in a post from jennifer uh days before
is that correct right
and you never spoke with jennifer about
that post no
um you testified that it was um
it was not appropriate
um
it would not be appropriate in your mind
for you to post something like that is
that correct
um it's fair to say you're not into guns
right it's fair to say you don't go to
the shooting range and enjoy that kind
of uh hobby correct
and um
the
based on jennifer's facebook there were
pictures of uh targets after they had
gone to a shooting range you saw those
as well yes
okay and you saw the photograph of the
of the guy yes
um
in terms of facebook overall jennifer
also posted about vacations camping
trips things along those lines is that
correct
she may have i really did i don't really
read people's feet since i don't know
okay did you go back and look at her
feed since um since the time that since
november 30th when everything unfolded
no
if i told you that there are photographs
family photographs things like that
would you be surprised no
when was it that you saw the math page
um during the day of november 30th who
showed you that that page andy smith
read it on his phone when he came into
my office
and then he pulled that up
while she was talking
did that happen when um
before or after the first call when
jennifer was on her way to the school
that was the first call
that i had i was on the phone
and i'm sorry so you saw this photograph
before that that phone call
no
i'm sorry tell me the order of the
events i'm missing it
smith came into my office
and put jen on the speaker phone was the
first i've heard of anything
and he brought that picture up on his
phone at that time while she was
talking hysterically trying to drive to
the school
you did not talk to her though about the
contents of that page anything on there
correct
it was the kind of thing where you're
having a conversation on speaker phone
and andy was showing you what jennifer
had sent to him right
and when when you looked at it you
thought um that boy needs help is that
correct right
and when you saw that drawing um
and knew that there was something going
on where mom was heading to the school
you didn't call police or anyone to make
anyone aware about this drawing is that
correct i mean
correct
and at that point um
[Music]
when you were speaking to jennifer
jennifer didn't go over the details on
the on the drawing with you
no
when you were on the phone
and
uh andy and you
uh had a conversation
um
were you were you aware that jennifer
was concerned ethan may be suicidal
yes did you become concerned that he was
suicidal
i i
too much was going on i didn't really
have time to think i was trying to
process what was going on
i did not know
the whole story
you would agree with me that that day
when you were dealing with jennifer
crumbly
she was processing a lot too and it was
a it was an unordinary day is that
correct yes
thank you
any questions
you weren't surprised by the
conversations you had with jennifer the
benefits and um
and getting money out and pay stubs and
you responded that you weren't correct
okay but were you surprised that just a
couple hours after her son
murdered children in a school she's
asking about her job
yes and she also asked you about
pictures did anything strike you unusual
when you actually
uh
cleaned out jennifer's desk
unusual
slightly what was that
your honor
may we approach please
what if any pictures can't be did you
find this dust on the desk
in the death story was a small photo
frame on her husband
in one of the dress drawers upside down
and the only other photos i
saw and found was a small picture of the
sun on her bulletin board
and a picture of a universe
if it was her horse or whatnot but it
was a picture
all right
okay sit down
one o'clock